as joe biden calls republicans racists
and flails aimlessly pundits begin
speculating about a hillary clinton 2024
run plus the federal reserve chairman
announces the end of stimulus and
inflation explodes i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first did you ever read that
fine print that appears every time you
start browsing incognito mode so you're
thinking hog needle mode means that you
are you know incognito wrong you are
that little notice says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your isp
is that even incognito to really stop
people from seeing the sites you visit
you need to do what i do and use
expressvpn think about all the times
you've used wi-fi at a coffee shop or a
hotel even at your parents house without
express vpn every site you visit could
be long by the admin of that network and
that's true even when you're in
incognito mode you really want a bunch
of outsiders looking at what you do on
the internet what's more your home
internet provider can also see and
record your browsing data and then sell
that to advertisers expressvpn stops all
that it's an app that encrypts all your
network data reroutes it through a
network of secure servers so your
private online activity stays just that
private i've been using expressvpn
myself for years because frankly it's
nobody's business what i'm using the
internet to do expressvpn works on all
your devices it is super easy to use the
app literally has one button you tap to
connect that's all now you're done stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
ben use my link expressvpn.com get three
extra months for free that's
expessvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so
the big news of the day is that joe
biden went down to georgia
looking for a soul to steal well sorry
wrong reference in any case he went down
to georgia in an attempt to drive up his
poll numbers and it is a giant failure
the reason that he went down to georgia
looking to drive up his poll numbers is
because democrats have decided that the
entire model for elections from now on
is going to be driving out the black
vote by shouting at black people that if
they don't vote for democrats
republicans are going to put them back
in chains now this shouldn't be a shock
because joe biden literally said that in
2012 about mitt romney mitt romney is
the single most milk toast human being
ever to have walked the earth mitt
romney is like the definite he's like
the oatmeal of human beings not like the
sweetened and salted oatmeal like the
actual just instant oatmeal that you get
from quaker oats and you pour it into a
bowl with water and not even whole milk
that's who mitt romney is and everybody
on the left treated him as anathema in
2012 up to and including joe biden who
suggested that he wanted to re-enslave
black americans so this has been their
pitch since 2012 essentially is that we
can win elections only if we scare black
people into voting for us in outsized
numbers that was joe biden's pitch down
in georgia yesterday to understand why
he is doing that you have to understand
that everything joe biden touches turns
to crap every single thing so he was
handed the possibility for the greatest
economic recovery
in american history because we had
artificially put the economy to sleep in
march of 2020 and then it had begun to
wake up by december of 2020 because the
vaccines were coming because people
recognized that they were gonna be able
to go back to work and joe biden took
office with vaccines ready to go and a
plan to distribute them ready to go
that should have been the end of the
pandemic instead it was not he decided
that he was going to artificially dump
trillions more dollars into the economy
for no apparent reason heating up
inflation he decided that he was going
to back the most
insane lockdown advocates who are
pushing for things like school closures
who's going to back people who are
pushing for endless rounds of boosters
before you could get back to work and
vax mandates at work and all the rest of
this
this is his fault
and now the federal reserve has
announced that the economy no longer
needs aggressive stimulus well there's
only one problem with this if the
federal reserve through its loose
monetary policy and joe biden's spending
policy created inflation
and meanwhile unemployment has gone down
to like 3.9 percent when they ratchet up
the inflation unemployment is likely to
go up because usually those two things
tend to work a little bit in tandem
when paul volcker then the federal
reserve chairman under ronald reagan
ratcheted up the interest rates in order
to curb inflation
the unemployment rate went up pretty
dramatically as well and so joe biden
can expect that to hit any time
now okay so yesterday the federal
reserve chairman jerome pell he called
high inflation a severe threat to a full
economic recovery that's a bit of a sea
change from five minutes ago when he was
saying that it was a transitory problem
he said tuesday the central bank was
preparing to raise interest rates
because the economy no longer needs
emergency support in fact he said we are
on an unsustainable debt path we've
spent way too much money and we can't
just inflate our way out of that
sustainable path debt is not an
unsustainable level but the path is
unsustainable meaning it's growing
faster than the economy meaningfully
faster than the economy we have to
address that over time we will address
it over time and the better way to do it
is soon and to do it in good times start
when the economy is strong and the taxes
are rolling in
and that's that's you know i since we
don't do fiscal policy but i will say
that this sustainability of the debt is
something we need to get back to
it's hilarious that jerome powell who
was just appointed by joe biden to
another term as fed chair
he is saying directly the opposite of
what joe biden has said joe biden says
that inflation can only be cured by
buildback better
and that the economy can only be helped
by buildback better and that we don't
have to worry about debts and deficits
and here's jerome powell saying oh yeah
we're going to ratchet down the
inflation and also we can't spend more
money
well he offered a few specifics powell
said that the central bank could begin
to shrink its 8.8 trillion portfolio of
bonds and other assets later this year
by the way the fed should not own 8.8
trillion dollars in bonds in other
assets that's insane it demonstrates how
much money they pumped into the economy
compared with a prior experience
shrinking the portfolio last decade the
process now could run sooner and faster
that much as cleary said we're gonna
have to be both humble and a bit nimble
the fed cut short-term interest rates to
near zero started buying bonds to lower
long-term rates in 2020 as the
covenpandemic hit the united states
economy triggering financial market
volatility in a deep short recession he
said it's time for us to begin to move
away from the emergency pandemic
settings to a more normal level it's a
long road to normal from where we are
and joe biden has to know that because
there are going to be some pretty severe
consequences to that at least in the
short term now pal is right this is
stuff that we have to do we have to
raise the interest rates and we should
not have spent a huge majority of the
money that we've spent over the past
couple of years keeping people at home
by the way joe biden is now calling for
trillions more in coveted spending
trillions more in coveted spending which
is insane
there's a reason his approval ratings
are in the low 40s high 30s at this
point meanwhile joe biden's democratic
party is pushing jerome powell to use
the inflationary power of the federal
reserve to fight climate change that's
how out of touch joe biden's democratic
party is here's senator elizabeth warren
with jerome powell yesterday
the issue really is can something from
climate change arise to the level that
would threaten this the stability of the
entire financial system so that sounds
like more in the in the nature of
of what you were reading something in
the nation of transition risk where some
unexpected court you know government
policy
uh change happens which which which
could potentially create
disruption yeah well the world is
running out of time to deal with the
climate crisis and the fed has an
important role to play here and i hope
the fed will step up
they are so crazy they're so crazy so
the fed has created this inflationary
spiral in tandem with the massive
spending bipartisan spending of 2020 and
the massive
spending binge that the bind
administration pushed in 2021 and
elizabeth for elizabeth warren is like
what if we use the federal reserve to
fight climate change
okay so again all of this is to explain
why joe biden is doing what he is doing
politically we'll get to that in just
one moment first have you ever gone
exclusive with somebody it's a pretty
big deal i remember when i went
exclusive with my wife very early on in
our relationship like a week in and it
was it was a big deal for me it was very
exciting almost as exciting as the fact
that we at the daily wire are now
exclusive with good ranchers the 100
american meat company once we laid eyes
on the stakes from good ranchers it was
hunger at first sight they sell beef
that is 100 born raised harvested here
in the united states that is a big deal
considering that 85 of the grass-fed
beef sold in stores and online is
imported from overseas with good
ranchers you help support local american
farms and ranches while getting
steakhouse quality cuts delivered
straight to your door i've met the
people who are in charge of good
ranchers let me tell you they are
wonderful great americans they win on
quality price and mission
that's why we are excited to partner
with them they take good care of us
they'll take great care of you they are
feeding the daily wire and feeding the
united states head on over to
goodranchers.com to get their biggest
offer ever that's 30 bucks off your
first order plus free express shipping
use code ben and check out or go to
goodranchers.com get 30 bucks off your
box of delicious unstoppably amazing
american meat order today to get
american meat delivered with good
ranchers go check them out
goodranchers.com
ben for their best offer ever already
the bite administration has no actual
plan and so their new plan is that
they're going to be recommending better
masks against omicron you good luck with
that gang seriously good luck with
n95ing your 12 year old
good luck with that
according to the washington post the
center for disease control is
considering updating its mass guidance
to recommend that people opt for the
highly protective n95k and 95 masks worn
by health per healthcare personnel if
they can do so consistently
while the highly transmissible omicron
variants spreading record levels of
infections and hospitalizations experts
have repeatedly urged the bite
administration to recommend the better
quality masks rather than cloth
coverings to protect against an airborne
virus and to underscore the importance
of masking the official said the agency
is currently actively looking to update
his recommendations for kn95 and n95
masks in light of oh mikron we know
these masks provide better filtration
so um the answer is going to be from the
american people that's a big no i'm not
putting my my kid in an n95 mask that's
insane you people are crazy you're crazy
everybody is gonna get omicron because
you can't live in a can 95 mask the rest
of your life everybody's going to get
this
everybody's going to be okay if you are
vaccinated or if you have natural
immunity and if you have neither natural
immunity nor vaccination then you are in
a certain amount of danger that is far
lower than the amount of danger that
delta provided
but again the the administration has put
itself in a box of its own making you
can't get out of this and this is why
you see videos of kids sitting outside
in virginia in 24 degree weather 24
degree weather eating lunch outside on
the ground in 24 degree weather to
prevent transmission of a virus that
will kill zero of these children a
story all these kids sitting outside
in hats and coats and gloves
it is 24 degrees outside
24 degrees
this is absolutely unacceptable
unacceptable
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable the
two of those kids are gonna die of
hypothermia you'll be out there
shivering
please imagine may i go inside no you
might get omicron
but i'm i'm freezing my little hands oh
that's turning blue shut up you might
give omicron's your classmate but my
classmate would be shut up
oh
my leg oh it's so
cold
something out of charles dickens at this
point this is so absurd it's but the
good news is according to joe biden
we're on the right track he's saying
that and by the way i do love it that
every time joe biden comes within five
feet of another human being he pulls
down his mask i'm not sure he
understands how this concept works so
he's got the mask is around his chin
he's two feet away from another human
yeah man
this guy's with us
i am concerned about the pandemic just
because it's worldwide it's not slowing
up very much
and uh thank god what we've been able to
do has enabled mr stupid i've been able
to
generate significant federal help in
terms of folks both
coming into the hospital
and administering all the help that
these states need that's what we're
doing now but i'm confident we're on the
right track
you confident we're on the right track
and then he just walks away no questions
catch you later by the way he did take
the mask all the way off presumably he
put it back on on the way to the
helicopter in the middle of the field
because he is not a bright human like it
is incredible to me that people somehow
consider joe biden bride uh it's just
it's beyond it's beyond reason i i don't
understand it he has never been the
brightest egg in the senate no one ever
thought that he was it was barack obama
who once
who once suggested that joe biden never
underestimate joe's ability to f things
up like that that is who joe biden is
and then we elected that guy president
and the american people decided we need
this daughter to be president of the
united states man we deserve whatever we
get from these people it is it is just
incredible meanwhile joe biden continues
to rely on anthony fauci the least
trusted public servant in america
anthony fauci to whom vote of candles
were lit despite the fact that he has
screwed up every element of this
pandemic response from his perch at the
nia id so in an interview yesterday he
suggested that he is not a political
person again
i just have a question isn't that a
picture of anthony fauci behind anthony
fauci am i is that is that correct
it does does he have a room in his house
where there's not a picture of anthony
fauci behind anthony vouch
it's wild man it's so wild everything is
a parody everything is is an ionuchi
parody movie at this point we can only
have public servants who serve the
public so much that they have pictures
of themselves behind them while they
speak in camera about themselves
so much public service going on he says
he's not a political person does anthony
fauci
i wish we could reset this and say you
have your political differences i'm not
a political person you know that for you
know me for decades zero political
interest but maybe we could put the
political stuff aside and say
why if we want to fight politically
let's end this outbreak first
get back to normal life and then go back
to our political ideologies
uh-huh
also uh he uh he then spent the the rest
of the day
in front of the senate just doing lap
dog service on behalf of the bite
administration so he says he thinks
biden's done a very good job on covet
yeah i'm i'm sure i'm sure
does that very good job involve more
deaths in 2021 than it did in 2020 with
the vaccines available
what what kind of um
what kind of good job would we be
discussing here doctor pouchy here we go
i think given the circumstances that
we're in right now i believe he's done a
very good job
i really do this this is an
extraordinary virus
the likes of which we have not seen even
close to in well over 100 years
it is a very wily virus it has fooled
everybody all the time from the time it
first came in to delta to now omicron
very unpredictable and we're doing the
best we possibly can
in no way has this been unpredictable
seriously in no way has been
unpredictable
every step of the way it's gotten more
transmissible and less deadly that is
the predictable pathway for viruses
throughout history
but that's the guy that joe biden has
chosen to trust saying that things are
going extremely well by the way dr
fought you then gotten another fight
with rand paul rand paul of course was
correct dr fauci was wrong and uh so dr
fauci decided to blame rand paul for his
own problems here's a bit of that
he's doing this for political reasons
what you need to do
is he said in front of this committee
you think your take down i was prominent
epidemiologist was not political you
don't want me to finish you know what
i'm going to say that was the question
what happens when he gets out
and accuses me of things that are
completely untrue
is that all of a sudden that kindles the
crazies out there and i have life that
threats upon my life
harassments of my family
and my children without seeing phone
calls
because people are lying about me
no one is lying that anthony fauci and
other members of the upper echelon of
the health administration actively
targeted the authors of the great
barrington declaration and tried to call
them nuts for disagreeing on their
policies with regard to the pandemic
anthony fauci great great public servant
terrific public servant okay so here is
the thing
all of this
leads to a simple fact joe biden is
failing he is flailing he's in serious
trouble and his response is going to be
republicans hate black people as always
this is the go-to democratic response
we'll get to that in just one second
first i'm thrilled to announce an
incredible app everyone who buys it gas
needs to know about get upside as you
already know my listeners are making up
to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up just download
that free get upside app in the app
store or google play right now use promo
code shapiro get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's up
to 50 cents cash back do not pay full
price at the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free use promo code shapiro get up
to 50 cents per gallon cash back on your
very first tank of gas some people who
drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks a month in cash back there
is no cash the cash back gets added
directly to your account you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or an egift card for amazon and other
brands just download the free get upside
app use promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your very
first tank of gas that is promo code
shapiro when you get that free get
upside app if you could be saving money
on gas like today why exactly would you
not be doing so head on over to the app
store or google play pick up that free
get upside app use promo code sharepoint
up to 50 cents per gallon cashback on
your first tank and 25 cents per gallon
after that okay so
all of this leads up to the simple fact
that joe biden is in trouble and so he
is going to go back to the well and that
well for democrats as always is everyone
who opposes me is a vicious racist now
this worked better for barack obama
because he was the first black president
joe biden is whiter than the back side
of the sheet of paper i'm currently
holding up joe biden is one of the
whitest people in america he's an 80
year old white man who is now who by the
way served in the senate with people
like george wallace
and
talked about how he had been praised by
people like george wallace in the 70s
not kidding
okay so so joe biden goes down to
georgia
and he decides that he is going to
rant and rave about how republicans are
trying to steal elections now i have to
say this is truly incredible it really
is so we've been hearing since november
of 2020 that it was the quote unquote
big lie right this is the media have
used the term big lie to apply to donald
trump's contention that the 2020
election was stolen i don't believe that
donald trump won the election or that
joe biden lost the won the election on
the basis of electoral fraud i think
there are a lot of things in the
election that were extremely corrupt i
think that the rejiggering of election
law in pennsylvania contrary to the
pennsylvania state constitution was
corrupt i think in any election with 155
million votes you're gonna get some
voter fraud i think that the media lied
i think the media prevaricated i think
they covered up for joe biden's failures
i think that they printed overt
falsehoods about donald trump i think
all of that can be true and i still
think that the 2020 election was not
quote unquote stolen in the way that
donald trump means it was stolen the
media however labeled that the big lie
now the reason they use the term big lie
is it is amazing the same media that
will say you can never make a holocaust
comparison a contention with that with
which i generally agree they're
consistently making holocaust language
comparisons when they say the big lie
what they mean is like hitler's big lie
and they're implicitly comparing the two
there's no question that's what they're
doing in the same way that when they
call you a climate change denier they're
essentially trying to hijack the
language of holocaust denial that is the
goal the goal is to take some of the
most charged language with regard to
human communication and then to slide it
into all of the american political
domestic talk
so donald trump was engaged in the big
lie over november of 2020. well i have a
question if it was a big lie for donald
trump to say that the election of 2020
was stolen through voter fraud
what would you say if i told you that
the democrats are now contending that
every election for the rest of time is
about to be stolen by republicans
that's what they're contending they're
now contending that if the republicans
are not stopped they will steal every
election for the rest of time which
implicitly means that if republicans win
democrats are going to challenge the
results of the election saying that the
election was stolen
i know that we're supposed to pretend
this is only a one-sided thing it is not
a one-sided thing stacey abrams from
georgia contended that the election for
governor a few years back was stolen
from her even though she lost by 50 000
votes that is not
donald trump's 12 000 votes in georgia
that's four times the margin 50 000
votes she lost by in georgia and she
still contended that the election was
stolen from her
and this has become part and parcel of
the democratic playbook in 2020 i know
that we're supposed to just erase the
history prior to november of 2020 of the
election but you will recall that it was
democrats who were claiming pretty
openly that if donald trump won it was
because he cheated
in fact post 2016 democrats claimed for
four years that donald trump won because
he cheated so now the new big lie okay
if we're gonna call it the big lie that
republicans lost the election of 2020 at
the presidential level because of voter
fraud
i'm going to say it's the biggest lie to
say that every election for the rest of
time will be stolen by republicans
unless joe biden gets to completely
rewrite election law in the united
states from the federal level that is
the biggest lie you can't imagine a
bigger lie what would the bigger lie be
really
if i say that one election was stolen
and that's untrue and then you say all
elections i lose are stolen all of them
which one is the bigger lie and yet the
media has no problem whatsoever just
trotting out joe biden's propagandistic
bull crap it's unreal
there is less evidence that voter
suppression is a massive problem in the
united states far less evidence that
voter suppression is a problem in the
united states and that there is some
element of voter fraud in elections
voter fraud is a minor issue as as far
as percentages of the total vote
and voter suppression is a non-issue
because it is a federal crime to
suppress the vote to stop people
actively from voting you can't do that
so what the hell are they talking about
this is the pitch and the pitch really
is to black americans
that if you don't stop the republicans
the republicans are going to stop you
from voting and we're going to go right
back to jim crow joe biden by the way is
not being subtle about this joe biden
has been saying for
a year at this point the republicans are
pursuing a new jim crow in the south
which is patently insane there's
currently a black democratic senator
from the state of georgia
stacy abrams is a real contender to be
governor of georgia
after being a terrible politician for
the past several years with regard to
the lies that she has told
joe biden
he he's constantly bragging about the
election results and then
it it it's so it is wild i mean on the
same at the same time you have
republicans many republicans who are
like yeah the election of 2020 was
stolen sure i got elected to a seat in
congress in that same election but the
election was stolen
joe biden does the exact same thing he's
like i won the election of 2020 but
but voter suppression's a real thing
barack obama won the elections of 2008
2012 but voter suppression is a real
threat
and what are you talking about what are
you talking about again the idea is
everyone who opposes joe biden is a
vicious racist now here's the thing
nobody actually believes this
there's pulling out from morning console
today and uh and morning consul polling
shows that americans literally do not
care about any of the issues joe biden
is talking about he's not talking to
anybody except his base
and in fact even members of his base are
not willing to to hear this because they
understand that this is incredibly
stupid so stacey abrams actually skipped
joe biden's speech in georgia last night
just skipped it she was like
nope
an aide for abrams told the new york
times she was unable to attend the event
in atlanta
despite her absence abram's expressed
support for the event welcoming biden
back to georgia on twitter yeah there's
a reason she didn't show up and maybe it
has to do with the fact that joe biden
is a 30 approval president in the state
of georgia and any attachment to joe
biden kills her in the state of georgia
joe biden had some words about this uh
he says that it was a scheduling mix-up
yeah joe uh that that's what
when when she refuses to go on a second
date with you
it's it's definitely the scheduling
mix-up not the fact that she doesn't
want to go on a date with you probably
here's here's joe biden
i spoke with stacy this morning had a
great relationship we got our scheduling
mixed up i'm going to be i've caught for
the length this morning
we're all on the same page and
everything's fine
and um and yeah by the way the mask is
down again as always the minute that he
gets in front of human beings within
five feet he takes the mass down because
he's a doddering old fool okay so then
on to the event
so the event itself
is
morally egregious i mean truly morally
egregious
really disgusting if you're going to
label people on the other side of the
aisle actual black hating confederates
you might want some evidence other than
georgia got rid of some of the drop
boxes that were temporarily set up for
covid times
you might want to get rid
you might want to provide some evidence
other than georgia's election law which
passed a few months back and is
apparently less strict than delaware
election law
but
again this is all it's uh it's the
biggest lie the biggest lie all
elections will be stolen if you don't
allow me to steal elections is joe
biden's is joe biden's pitch okay so
vice president kamala harris she let off
he's just dragging her around at this
point trying to make kamala harris a
thing you're never making fetch a thing
man it is not happening fetch will not
be a thing
and she's terrible she's just awful at
this i don't know why he bothers trying
to trot her out at this point as we will
see nobody else takes kamala hara
seriously like how not seriously is
kamala harris being taken if joe biden
were to keel over before the 2020
election before the 2024 election
democrats have somebody else in mind
already anyway here is kamala harris
making the absurdly stupid claim that uh
gop anti-voter laws are going to
disenfranchise 55 million people pulling
this number directly out of her ass
across our nation anti-voter laws could
make it more difficult for as many as 55
million americans to vote
that is one out of six people in our
country
um i i would like some
evidence that 55 million people are not
going to vote because republicans say
you have to show voter id
like some evidence that would be great
okay then joe biden gets up there and
again he's making a pitch on an issue no
one cares about no one cares about this
no one the entire shtick here is can i
scare black people into voting for me
despite the fact i'm a crappy president
by the way i will tell you that the new
inflation stats are out again the reason
he's doing this is because he is dead in
the water come 2022 he's got real
problems come 2024 aside from his own
health
which obviously is not good
according to the the brand new numbers
from the us government inflation climbed
to 7
in december seven percent on on an
annualized basis that is the highest
level since 1982 december was the eighth
month that inflation has been at five
percent or higher
that was driven by shelter used cars and
food energy actually fell slightly
uh amazing amazing stuff so joe biden
he's again can he scare enough black
people into voting for him by shouting
that his opponents are jefferson davis
confederates he starts by saying we're
calling on congress to get this done
okay here's the problem dude congress is
controlled by your party you
you have 50 votes in the senate
you haven't you have a majority in the
house you are the president of the
united states you can't get people to
sign off on killing the filibuster
for your ridiculously usurpatious voting
law because no one backs it
here's jobiden trying to run against the
congress he controls
today
we call on congress to get done what
history will judge
pass the freedom to vote act
as our um old man shouts at clouds have
we calling congress to pass the freedom
to vote deadly
okay then he gets even better then he
suggested anyone who doesn't
back his proposal to kill the filibuster
which until five minutes ago democrats
were in love with
in fact before the democrats took the
senate the democrats used the filibuster
about a couple hundred times a year
against republican legislation here's
joe biden
saying that anyone who disagrees with
him on this bill is on the side of
george wallace again he served with
george wallace in the senate and uh he
used to brag about their relationship
bull connor and jefferson davis
jefferson davis that's right if you
don't back
his proposal to federalize all election
procedure federalize ballot harvesting
force the federal government to overlook
every redistricting scheme in the united
states
if you don't support all of that you are
on the side of people who actively
enslaved black people in the united
states and then fought a war ending with
the death of three quarters of a million
americans in order to preserve slavery
you're on the side of those people if
you don't back this old white man who
actually remembers the civil war it is
unclear which side joe biden fought on
at the time here is joe biden
i ask every elected official in america
how do you want to be remembered
at consequential moments in history
they present a choice
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
this is the moment to decide i feel like
the the decision is to whether to be on
the side of
george wallace or martin luther king was
like 1968 and we came down on the side
as a country of martin luther king and
and when it came to john lewis versus
bull conor i feel like that decision was
made also
in that period and we came down on the
side
of
of john lewis and i feel like the
decision about abraham lincoln versus
jefferson davis that decision came down
circa about 1865. so i'm not sure what
he's talking about he's not sure what
he's talking about all he knows is if he
can yell at black people maybe those
black people will go vote for an old
white man and his friends
it's truly incredible i don't know what
he thinks his electoral strategy here is
broadly speaking except he just keeps
doubling down on stupid they just keep
doubling down on stupid it's incredible
joe biden finishes up by saying trump
and the gop want to disenfranchise
anyone who votes against them
so again
this is a huge lie this is a huge lie
the media won't call it out but it is in
fact the biggest lie that if republicans
win in the future it must be because
they disenfranchise millions of people
the goal the former president's allies
is to disenfranchise anyone who votes
against them simple as that
the facts won't matter
your vote won't matter they'll just
decide what they want
and then do it
there's the universe
okay so that guy is a giant fail of a
human i mean i mean he's an immoral
human being if your job is that you go
out there and you suggest that your
political opponents are vicious brutal
slave pro-slavery racists because they
oppose you on your voting procedures act
in 2021 i don't know what to say about
you other than you are acting deeply
immorally and joe biden is an immoral
dirty scummy politician he really really
is i know we're supposed to pretend that
he's pure as the driven snow while his
son is running around the world picking
up bags of cash thanks to his last name
and admitting it on national television
i know we're supposed to pretend that
this dullard is somehow an intelligent
human being after riding barack obama's
coattails to fame being plucked from
obscurity specifically because he was an
older white gentleman
hey i know we're supposed to pretend
that this person whose sole legislative
accomplishment his entire career
was the 1994 crime bill which he then
ran directly away from in the last
election cycle in order to pander to the
woke base
but he is a dirty immoral scummy
politician purgate and what he is doing
right now is dirty immoral and scummy i
know we're supposed to pretend that he
didn't say about again i'm never gonna
get over this i will not get over the
fact that he suggested that mitt romney
wanted to re-enslave black people
i'm never gonna get over that fact
that that that is like saying
that
mother teresa
was very very interested in promoting
prostitution like what are you talking
about what are you even saying right now
mitt romney wasn't saying that about
like donald trump you're saying that
mitt romney this guy has no limits he's
a congenital liar
he is immoral and and and the media
refused to call him out because there's
lap dogs it's unreal
okay but but people are starting to see
down the road and what they realize is
that the the doddering elderlies who
currently run the democratic party
uh they are they are in trouble and so
someone has a solution wait until wait
until you hear this this is pretty wild
we'll get to that in just one second
first if somebody relies on your
financial support then you really should
get life insurance i mean let's say that
you are the captain of a whaling ship
and you become obsessed obsessed with
going after a whale that took your leg
and so you lead a pack of men on this
ship
into the middle of the ocean and you get
into a knockdown drag out brawl with
this giant white whale well
as you sink your harpoon into the whale
and that whale drags you out to see you
might be thinking to yourself number one
this is a bad move and number two i
probably should have gotten life
insurance for mrs ahab well if that's
you you should have checked out
policygenius.com shapiro you can answer
a few questions about yourself in
minutes
you can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius their licensed experts
will help you understand your options
and apply for a policy the policy genius
team works for you not the insurance
companies you can trust them to offer
unbiased help and advocate for you at
every step until you are covered policy
genius does not add on extra fees they
don't sell your information in third
parties they have thousands of five-star
reviews across google and trust pilot
there's a reason that policy genius has
helped over 30 million people shop for
insurance placed 120 billion dollars in
coverage since 2014 alone head on over
to policygenius.com shapiro get your
free life insurance quotes see how much
you could save alrighty we're going to
get to the democratic backup plan in a
second because it's really really funny
first
as everybody now knows the daily wire is
rapidly expanding into entertainment man
i cannot wait to bring you the news
about all the stuff we're going to do
but here's the thing you can be a part
of it we are searching right now
for a council of business and legal
affairs to join our legal team in
nashville as our in-house legal expert
on the film and tv industry the council
of business and legal affairs will
manage all the legal aspects of the
daily wires entertainment content
including development acquisition
production and finance as well as
production legal
and intellectual property work for all
daily wire shows we need somebody with
eight plus years of experience in the
film and tv industry is a perfect
opportunity for an entertainment lawyer
who's ready to get out of hollywood's
woke group thing to apply for that
opening and to view a full list of our
current openings at daily wire please
visit dailywire.com
careers you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so if you are a democrat and you're
looking at the future of the democratic
party what you have on your hands is a
disaster area you have in the house of
representatives an elderly woman nancy
pelosi 80 years old whose eyebrows have
now receded all the way to the back of
her head and her face has ceased to move
she looks exactly like the like the doll
cheeto from life in pieces at this point
and her brain works similarly you have a
president of the united states who's no
longer with us he's not been with us for
quite some time every so often somebody
pulls the string on his back and out
comes a series of sounds that seem to
mimic words and mostly say things about
how his political opponents are racist
you pull the string he goes he goes
to jefferson dave i said no no
yeah they got that guy and then
backing that guy up you have kamala
harris his affirmative action pick
not my
take his take he specifically said he
was searching for a black woman so if i
point out that he was searching for a
black woman and found one
that's not controversial that's just a
simple fact he was searching for a black
woman he found one the problem is she's
very very bad at this a woman so bad at
this
that every time she's asked anything
remotely approaching a difficult
question she breaks into a bizarre
cackle like walking phoenix in joker
okay so if you're a democrat and you're
looking forward to the future maybe you
look to that younger cadre right and so
what exactly is the younger cadre well
kamala is younger and she's terrible
then you've got pete budaj whose entire
pitch for being president of the united
states is that he's into dudes that's
literally his entire pitch he's a failed
mayor of south bend indiana he was not
good at being mayor he ran statewide he
lost
and then he ran for president and he
and now he's the secretary of
transportation in the middle of a vast
supply chain crisis and he took two
months off and no one noticed for
paternity leave where no one had
suffered a physical injury
and um and that's the guy where they're
like he should probably be president
mainly because he's gay because let's
face it if people who judge were not gay
no one would even be no no one knows his
name i mean it is it is that simple so
the democrats are going back to the
drawing board and some are suggesting
wait for it wait for a wait for it
they're going to go back to hillary
clinton
okay
okay guys the well that you're going
back to by the way here is the hilarious
thing about hillary clinton hillary
clinton is past her prime right hillary
clinton is way past her prime hillary
clinton is wait for it how old is she
hillary clinton is 74 years old
donald trump is 75 years old
joe biden will be 80 years old running
for re-election
okay so hillary clinton is a spring
chicken compared to all of the above
joe biden is 79 years old right now
okay this means
if i get my math right that he will be
81 years old running for president of
the united states next time around
on the other side of the aisle he got
donald trump who's widely perceived to
be
wanting to run for re-election donald
trump will be 77 to 78 years old by the
time that he runs for president again
hillary clinton will be 76 years old so
by the by comparison she is basically
like one of the kids from greece
okay so according to to
douglas
shane and andrew stein writing for the
wall street journal perhaps perhaps
hillary clinton should make a comeback
by the way there's nothing hillary
clinton would love better than this
she's already they say in an
advantageous position to become the 2024
democratic nominee she's an experienced
national figure who is younger than
biden and can offer a different approach
from the disorganized and unpopular one
the party is currently taking can she
though also is she that much younger
you're basically moving from the from
the from hospice to the assisted living
facility to search for candidates at
this point
if democrats lose control of congress in
2022 clinton can use the party's loss as
a basis to run for president again
enabling her to claim the title of
change candidate and good luck with that
based on her latest public statements
it's clear clinton not only recognizes
her position as a potential frontrunner
but also is setting up a process to help
her decide whether or not to run for
president again she recently warned of
the electoral consequences in the 2022
midterms if the democratic party
continues to align itself with its
progressive wing and urged democrats to
reject far-left positions isolating key
segments of the electorate
clinton took a veil jab at the baton
administration she said it means nothing
if we don't have a congress that will
get things done and we don't have a
white house that we can count on to be
sane and sober and stable and productive
even bill clinton is setting the stage
for his wife's potential 2024 candidacy
referring to her in an interview with
people as quote the most qualified
person to run for office in my lifetime
including me adding that not electing
her in 2016 was one of the most profound
mistakes we ever made
we can infer based on these recent
remarks that mrs clinton would seize the
opportunity to run for president again
what are the odds and opportunity will
arise well biden's overall job approval
rating is 40 his rating on issues
including the economy and jobs is 38
percent taxes in government spending at
33 barring a major course correction
some democrats will lose important house
and senate races in 2022.
hillary clinton remains ambitious
outspoken and convinced that if not for
fbi director james comey's intervention
and russian interference she would have
won 2016. so man 2024 grudge match
hillary clinton donald trump it's just
what america deserves
yeah man go for it guys this is the best
you can do
yeah our country might be in some
trouble here all righty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content in the meantime go check out
the michael knowles show in today's show
he discusses usa today trying to
normalize pedophilia you can hear more
details about that story over on
michael's show that is available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo widowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
joe biden demands democrats rewrite our
election laws ted cruz corners the fbi
on its involvement in the capital riot
and usa today tries to normalize
pedophilia check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]